[Music]
there were moments when kais chowdy's
parents feared he wouldn't make it
one of the youngest in belgium to be
hospitalized with covid19
the days the four-year-old spent in a
medically induced coma the most
terrifying time for his family
his father says doctors initially
dismissed his high temperature as a
childhood fever
and sent him home it's hard it's hard
because
you see your your baby child in in this
situation and
it's very very hard to see that
and it is making many
emotion with kais now improving his
parents are trying to restart their
clothing business
but have launched a facebook campaign to
make other parents aware of the risks to
children
and the symptoms to watch for kya's
developed blotches on his skin before
finally being tested for kovid i want to
inform the people this covid 19 is very
dangerous also for the
for the children not only for the old
people
the childish are just one family amongst
thousands every day now in belgium
having to deal with covet 19.
cases are rising here faster than almost
anywhere else in europe
and a leading virologist has told sky
news the government made a big mistake
easing restrictions at the start of this
month such as how many people could meet
getting rid of the the bubble of five
that was not a good idea suddenly more
people
were able to meet more people that is
exactly what the virus needs the virus
needs people meeting people
and he predicts the most extreme step a
national lockdown will be needed soon to
bring the virus
under control i would have done it
yesterday
for sure a short lockdown to really
bring the numbers down
to a manageable level um
saving christmas that would be that
would be one of the results that you
could have
close social contact outside the home is
now limited to one person in belgium
bars and restaurants have been closed
and in brussels the wearing of masks in
public
is once again obligatory
the challenge is to get people to comply
which is why a group of young people in
the capital have produced this video to
get others their age
to take kovid seriously but my personal
even with compliance many believe
lockdown is now inevitable
it might not be popular but given the
numbers it may well be necessary
michelle clifford sky news brussels